Музыка Musik Eine neue Reise beginnt mit unseren beiden Recken vom Das-Podcast-Uvo.
Mit Florentin Will.
Und Stefan Tietze.
Florentin Will an der Armbrust.
Stefan Tietze am Flegel.
Am was?
Flegel.
Ich bin kein Flegel.
Du hast ein Flegel.
Am was?
Das ist eine Art Waffe.
So ein langer Stock mit einem anderen Stock dran.
Ein anderer Stock dran? Ja. Wie? Du hast doch gesagt, als ich gesagt habe, wer will mir helfen, hast du gesagt, Und dann ist es auch ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen es gibt diese Szene mit Gimli, er heißt aber Gomli oder sowas, und er sagt, und du hast meine Armbrust, und du hast meine helle Bade und mein Streitkolb.
Und dann gab es diesen Cultural Appropriation Ninja, der irgendwie Nunchucks dazu gescheitert hat oder sowas, der nicht wirklich in diese Fantasywelt reinpasst, aber das ist ja auch egal. Ich freue mich sehr zu einer neuen Folge, dass du erschienen bist. Ich freue mich auch, dass wir dieses Thema direkt beenden konnten am Anfang und haben es aus dem Weg geschafft. Andreas dirigiert heute das Grosse, das Podcast UFO Orchestra hier live aus Köln. Aber wie cool, also machst du das beruflich? Hm, ja? Ja? Das ist dein Hauptberuf, du komponierst Musik? Wow, krass. Aber für wen denn zum Beispiel? What? Wirklich? Da darfst du aber nicht drüber reden, oder? Und was hat der gesagt? War der cool? Also privat, weil man denkt, der hört ja Geschichten. Moment, das heißt, das ist gar nicht von ihm, sondern das war von dir? Krass, weil dann hättest du ja eigentlich auf der Bühne stehen müssen und nicht. Okay, wann kommt ein Problem? Okay. Und wie, und hat sie sich direkt danach getrennt von dir oder was, weil du den Scheid jetzt nicht bekommen hast oder? Ah, okay, okay. Wie, und hat sie sich direkt danach getrennt von dir, oder was, weil du den nicht bekommen hast, oder? Ah, okay, gut. Das war es noch wert am Ende, oder? War es nicht wert? Also wenn du rückblickend jetzt nochmal guckst, das ist ja schon ein paar Jahre her. Eben. War es das nicht wert? Ich meine... Nee, du brauchst ja gar nicht jetzt, also du brauchst ja nicht weinen, also wer macht... Das tut mir jetzt leid, das war jetzt... Okay, es tut mir jetzt leid, Andreas. Das war unempathisch lohnt. Nein, ich wollte es ja irgendwie positiv nochmal in ein anderes Licht drücken. Ja, aber du hast ja auch nicht durchgesagt, noch zu kämpfen. Ja, okay, aber man muss es ja auch irgendwann abschliessen können. Das bringt ja nichts, wenn du jahrelang dann einfach das nicht anredest. Andreas, du, sorry, wir machen es, wir kürzen es hier ab. Wir bedanken uns bei dir, danke für das Intro, tschüss, das war Andreas, meine Damen und Herren. Wahnsinn, also das wollte ich immer haben, so ein Intro, so ein Abenteuerfilm Intro, wo wir beiden über so einen Hügel gehen, in Akt zwei rein, wo uns blüht, was wir gelernt haben, was in Akt eins bereits gesagt wurde, was uns da blüht und wir wollten es nicht, aber dann haben wir uns, wurden wir doch überred haben wir einen Montmentor getroffen noch auf dem Weg, einen Zauberer. Und wir haben schon ein paar Hürden überwunden, aber unsere Hürde, die zwischen uns steht, haben wir noch nicht richtig überwunden. Aber das wird auch noch ein bisschen dauern. Und das wird auch noch ein bisschen dauern. Bis zum Finalkampf. Ja, auf jeden Fall, bis dahin noch kommen. Wenn einer von uns nicht dabei ist, der den anderen verlassen hat, aber dann zum Finalkampf wird dann doch noch wieder auftaucht. Genau. Das Publikum denkt, oh mein Gott, Stefan ist wieder da. Stefan ist wieder da. Und er hat das Buch dabei. Er hat in der Zwischenzeit das ganze Buch abgeschrieben und es war die ganze Zeit eine Fälschung. Und als wir dachten, das Buch geht ins Feuer, hatte er die ganze Zeit noch eine Abschrift zu Hause liegen. Deswegen war er beim Ball nicht dabei war ja das buch wir dachten alle er ist
ein versager und hat niemanden für den ball gefunden das hässliche nerd mädchen ist jetzt wunderschön sie hat die brille abgesetzt und hat hat neue haare und sie ist jetzt wunderschön und sie ist mit stephan zusammen sie küssen sich mit zunge jetzt am endkampf sie küssen sich fast Nur Zunge. every film ever um ehrlich zu sein ich glaube ich könnte von außen gar nicht zung küssen ich kann ich glaube ich kann gar nicht sehen ob ob irgendwas ein zungenkuss ist oft haben oft sagen leute so ja und dann irgendwie das und das zungenkuss und ich dachte hä wie ich dachte es nur so ein wie also du kannst ja also Normalerweise denkt man, Zungenkuss ist ja dachte, hä? Wie, ich dachte, das ist nur so ein... Wie, also...
Du kannst ja, also, normalerweise denkt man,
Zungenkuss ist ja ganz intensiv, so dass man
sich so richtig reinlegt, aber du kannst ja auch
nur so ein... Man kann andeuten. So ein Bussi
kannst ja auch noch so ein bisschen Zunge mitspielen, so
Tschüss. Oh jei.
So, aber das ist sofort unangenehm,
wenn Partner, Partnerin dich mitspielt,
wenn die Signale falsch verstanden werden
und du bist der Einzige, der so... Ich finde das Quatsch, dass Zunge reserviert ist für diese ultra ineinander geschlungenen Zungenkusssequenzen. Ich finde, man kann auch zu einem süssen auf die Wange, Bussi, kann man auch mal die Zunge. Die Zunge hat ja auch eine Spitze. Ja, okay, dann kriegst du ab jetzt einen French-Wangenkuss. Ja, oder auch so zu begrgrüssung, wenn man so, ah, bussi, bussi, einfach mal so links, rechts mit angedeuteter Zunge noch mal. Oder auf die Stirn. Ja, genau. So einen Kuss, also, kennt man ja. Ja, warum denn nicht? Wenn der Onkelein zum Abschied auf die Zunge, äh, auf die Stirn küsst, mit Zunge. Ja. Boah. Zunge ist schon was der Entzündung.
Man sagt ja immer, Zunge ist der stärkste Muskel des Körpers. Nach dem Gesäss. Nach dem steinharten Gesäss, aber so richtig nutzt, also ich habe nicht das Gefühl, dass ich ihn richtig ausnutze, oder? Ich habe das Gefühl, der ist relativ, naja, heute wieder nur Nudeln. Nur Nudeln, heute hatte ich nur Nudeln. Das ist wie wenn du halt so einen Sportwagen hast und mit jemandem dreissig in der Fußgängerzone fährst oder so. Du fährst ihn nicht aus. Du fährst ihn nicht aus. Ist ja auch nicht gut. Ist ja auch nicht gut. Nein, du musst ihn fahren. Ein Sportwagen will gefahren werden, eine Zunge will benutzt werden. Ja, absolut. Und da kommt jetzt das Zungentraining, das Florentinwill Zungentraining. Haben sie eine schlaffe Zunge. Unilingus, das ist dein verschriebenes Zungentraining, das Florentin-Will-Zungentraining.
Haben Sie eine schlaffe Zunge? Unilingus, das ist dein verschriebenes Zungentraining. Du kriegst eine Form für Eiswürfel, aber die sind nicht einfach nur Würfel, sondern verschiedenste Formen. Du hast zum Beispiel einfach nur so ein Brett, also wie so ein Quadrat, wo deine Aufgabe ist, du musst mit der Zunge durchkommen. Also ganz kleine Kreise, ganz kleines Stochern, um durch diese Mauer durchzukommen, um deine Zungenkraft. Genau, du musst dich durchzüngeln. Du musst dich durchzüngeln. Ja, finde ich gut. Also so Übungssets, schwerer werden Übungssets, Eiswürfel für die Zunge. Genau. Und dann gibt es noch Gewichte, die du auf der Zunge hoch und runter deine Zunge, ich finde, die Zunge sollte so stark sein, dass du dir selber die Zähne brechen kannst. Dass du selber einfach einfach den Zahn wegbrechen kannst. Du kannst jetzt zum Beispiel nicht den Finger abbeissen, das ist so das Ding. Genau, deswegen kannst du vielleicht nicht deine Zähne rausdrücken, wo die Zunge das eigentlich könnte.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe kaum Kontrolle über meine Zunge.
Ich war auch beim Zahnarzt letztens und dann hieß es dann so, so, jetzt auf gar keinen Fall mit der Zunge den Zahn berühren. Ja, und ich denke mir, ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wo meine Zunge ist gerade so. Wissen Sie, wo Ihre Zunge ist?
Nehmen Sie die vom Gaumen weg.
Was?
Genau, und dann meinte er auch so, ne, und jetzt bin ich noch ein bisschen runter.
Und ich dachte mir so, hä, wo ist meine Zunge, wenn nicht unten?
Und in der Zeitung Vom Gaumen weg. Was? Genau, und dann meinte er auch so, nehm ich jetzt mal noch ein bisschen runter und ich dachte mir so, hä, wo ist meine Zunge, wenn nicht unten? Und er so, ne, Sie müssen jetzt noch einmal die Zunge runternehmen und ich dachte mir so, kann ich mich melden und sagen, Entschuldigung, Herr Doktor, ich habe keine Kontrolle über meine Zunge. Ich weiss, wo meine Zunge ist. Grob hier und da, wenn ich ein Eiss esse, abgesehen davon, macht die, was ihr will. Kann man das machen? Eigentlich ist es eine gute Achtsamkeitsübung. Seid euch bewusst, wo eure Zunge ist. Und dann dachte ich mir, ist auch so eine weirde Kapitel drei bei Headspace. Herzlich willkommen zu Headspace. Atmen Sie tief ein und aus. Sie haben eine Zunge in ihrem Mund. Da ist sie. Sie liegt wie ein F Und jetzt spüren Sie Ihre Zunge. Werden Sie sich bewusst, wo Ihre Zunge ist. Und denken Sie mal nach, wo endet denn die Zunge? Sie haben eine Spitze, aber wie weit geht die Zunge eigentlich rein? Woraus besteht diese Zunge eigentlich? Und was kommt danach eigentlich? Was kommt nach Zunge? Wo hört die Zunge auf? Wo geht's da rein? Und dann wird selber der Sprecher so... Im Ernst?
Nee, jetzt mal mal ernst kurz, wo die Zunge...
Weil die Zunge ist ja eigentlich... geht die nicht in den Hals...
Und der Sprecher erstickt, das geht einfach weiter.
Das geht einfach weiter. Diese Musik hört nicht auf, diese Lala-Musik.
Diese Lala-Musik.
Es werden ja heutzutage so viele Hörbücher produziert,
da muss, also
es gibt ja,
also ich meine, es gibt ja dann immer wieder so
beim Film geht was schief,
hier, guck mal. Bloopers.
Nee, auch im Film.
Wie, im Film geht was im Film schief?
Ja, dass man irgendwie, guck mal,
also klassisch bei Herr der Ringe, da fällt jemandem das Schwert aus der Scheide oder so im Hintergrund. Wurde einfach den gelassen, weiß man nicht so. Easter Eggs. Das hätte ich gerne mal. Nee, nee, nee. Filmfehler. Nee, ich weiß, dass du viele Begriffe aus der Filmwelt kennst und das ist super und aber das ist einfach der Fall. Schnappstappe. Nee, einfach überhaupt Fehler die passieren und dann im Film bleiben so exaktischer Beat Sheet nein nein nein und das hätte ich gerne mal für Hörbücher also so ein YouTube Video Compilation von Hörbüchern wo jemand sagt und dann zack und dann zog dann zog Arrogant sein Schwert. Arrogant. Und zeugte Arrogant sein Schwert. Und es ist einfach durchgekommen, es hat einfach niemand gemerkt. Ach so, ach so. Es ist einfach durchgekommen, sondern es ist einfach so, genau wie Bally the Cumberbatch mit Penglings und Penguins, der in der Doku das Wort falsch sagt, ist einfach drin. Und daran unterscheiden wir uns, weil ich will nichts mehr, weil ich will nichts
mehr als die
Off-Takes, also die
Bloopers von
Out-Takes.
Das ist ein
großer Unterschied zwischen uns beiden. Das ist tatsächlich,
ich glaube, da kommen wir nicht mehr zusammen. Wir sind sehr viel,
also wir sind sehr harmonisch, wir können uns
oft wirklich, sind wir einer Meinung
und wir vertrauen uns doll,
aber da sind wir ein großer, da sind wir ein großer
Unterschied, da unterscheiden wir uns sehr,
Ich bin ein sehr guter, sehr guter, sehr guter, wir können uns oft wirklich, sind wir einer Meinung und vertrauen uns doll. Aber da sind wir ein grosser, da sind wir ein grosser Unterschied. Da unterscheiden wir uns sehr. Denn ich, während du die Filmfehler quasi in einem Hörbuch möchtest, möchte ich gerne die Outtakes hören. Und ich glaube, da kommen wir nicht zusammen. Und da gab es auch schon ein paar Streits zwischen Florian und Dynamien. Ja, das können wir jetzt mal kurz hinter die Kulissen ein bisschen blicken lassen, weil da haben wir uns schon richtig gezofft. Da haben wir uns richtig in die Haare bekommen, ja. Weil ich dachte, nee, es wäre doch cooler, wenn, also, es wäre doch witzig, wenn du ein Hörbuch hörst und dann das eben nicht erwartest, dass das falsch ist. Nee, wie gesagt, das wäre nicht so lustig. Ich würde mein Hörbuch genießen können, aber ich würde dann gern in einem geregelten Maße danach irgendwie die Outtakes hören. Ja, aber du weißt ja dann schon, dass es falsch ist, wenn du dann die Outtakes hörst aber ihr seht schon du weißt ja schon da werden wir da können wir stundenlang da können wir stundenlang wer rechte es gehört ja auch zu einer gesunden beziehung dazu so ein paar dinge zu haben wo man sich einander reibt man muss sich nicht bei allem übereinstimmen ich meine da da sind wir jetzt einfach anderer meinung und stefan hat da einfach andere ansprüche aber ich glaube die meisten würden mir recht geben aber bei stefan ist es halt ja aber ich habe immer ich habe immer rumgefragt im Freundeskreis und da waren schon die meisten, ich habe auch rumgefragt und mir haben alle gesagt, nee, da hast du völlig recht, okay, das kann nicht sein, okay, das kann erstens nicht sein, weil ich auch mehr Leute kenne als du, das glaube ich nicht, es nehmen mir vier Leute, Bernhard, Bianca, Bibi, Tim und Schruppi,
die haben ich auch alle gefragt.
Okay, aber ich glaube,
ich habe dann doch noch einen besseren Draht zu denen.
Bibi, Tina, Amadeus,
Sabrina, auch die habe ich alle gefragt.
Ich glaube, dass ich einen besseren Draht zu denen habe und dass sie vielleicht
zu dir auch nicht immer ehrlich sein. Zu mir haben die gesagt,
Florentin kam auch schon zu uns,
das fanden wir ziemlich nervig.
Wer hat das gesagt? Sabrina. das fährt offensichtlich ja genau wie bei er captain blaubehr der hat ja diese drei kinder die schlicht keine namen haben die heißen grün gelb pink ja die habe ich mir verwechselt mit tick trick habe die immer verwechselt mit Tick, Trick und Track. Weil der Käpt'n ist ja auch der Vater, oder? Und der hat mit Käpt'n Blaube die Kinder? Nein, Moment, sorry, Käpt'n Blaube ist ja der Käpt'n. Nein, Hein Blöd ist die Mutter. Hein Blöd und Käpt'n Blaube haben Tick, Trick und Track? Nein. Oder es sind immer Onkel, es ist immer Onkelbeziehung, nie Vater. Oder ich weiß weiss gar nicht, ob bei Käpt'n Blaubeer das die Kinder sind, aber mit welchen Wesen hat er dann drei Kinder, das eines rot, ist eines blau? Ich weiss nicht, wie immer die aussehen. Das sind halt kleine Bären, aber es wäre auch gut, wenn er ist Käpt'n Blaubeer und eines seiner Kinder ist blau und die anderen nicht. Und sehen genauso aus wie Hein Blöd, offensichtlich wie Hein Blöd. Hein Blöd ist ja eine Ratte, ne? Ne, doch. Eine gelbe. Schiffsratte. Das gelb. Weil das sind ja die Tiere, die du am ehesten auf einem Schiff findest, die Ratte und der Bär. Eine menschengrosse Ratte namens Hein Blöd ist sehr naheliegend. Ja, das ist direkt aus dem Leben gegriffen. Walter Mörs war ja auch viel unterwegs auf See. Und war sau faul, sich Dinge auszudenken. Ja, richtig faul. Ich kann dir empfehlen, die dreizehneinhalb Leben des Käpt'n Blaubeeren. Heißt das so? Die dreizeinhalb Leben des Käpt'n Blaubeeren. Nee, Moment, noch mal, ich sag's noch mal. Das Buch ist so toll. Des Blaubeeren. Lest es euren Kindern vor, lest es euren Partnerinnen und Partnern vor, lest es allen vor, lest es selbst. Die dreizehnhalb Leben des Käpt'n Blaubeeren. Walter Mörs Roman. Die tollen Abenteuer des Lucky Lux sind. Die grossen Abenteuer des Asterix und Obelixes. Fucking, fucking Genitiv, ey, lass uns das einfach abschaffen. Die dreizehneinhalb Leben des Käpt'n Blaubeer. Habe ich sehr gerne gelesen, toll illustriert, macht Spaß. Und da kennt man so ein bisschen die Origin-Story, hat nichts mit der Serie zu tun, die man kennt und liebt, auch liebt. Also wir müssen es irgendwie hinkriegen, beide Universen
parallel in eurem Kopf koexistieren
zu lassen. Toll. Und
jetzt,
was, wenn man jetzt so mal so
allgemein in die Medienlandschaft schaut, was könnte jetzt kommen?
Naja, ich glaube, du weißt, was jetzt kommt.
Nein. Naja, ich glaube, es ist
relativ offensichtlich, was jetzt kommt.
Wenn wir gerade bei Captain Blaubeer waren
und du gesagt hast, das ist ja gar nicht so origineinell weil jetzt mal ganz kurz Fakten auf den Tisch es gibt ja Balou und seine Crew es gibt nur Bären es gibt Balou den Bären es gibt Barney Das ist kein Bär. Ich meine, den Bär im großen blauen Haus. Ja.
Es gibt Charmin Bär, Captain Blaubär, Winnie Poo, Charmingoo, Charmingbär, Poo-Bär, die Gummibärchen-Bande und die Gummiglücksbärchen. Es gibt alles nur Bären. Bären sind so überrepräsentiert im Kinderbewusstsein. Und dann wirst du erwachsen und merkst, ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben Bären gesehen. Selbst im Zoo, im Bärengehege sieht man keine Bären.
Ne, die Bären haben alle einen Job. Die haben alle einen Job in der Medienbranche. Das ist einfach eine komplette Tierart, die komplett von der Medienbranche einfach einverleibt wurde. Es gibt kaum noch wilde Bären, weil die alle gebraucht werden für Fotoshoots, Werbung, Dreh, irgendwie so. Der ist halt so der Showtier. Tanzbär? Tanzbär, ja, das istTier letzten Endes. Warte, haben die getanzt oder war das nicht so? Ja, ja, klar, so Breakdance. Die haben sich dann so auf den Rücken gedreht. Ich hatte so Barely Tanzbewegungen, irgendwie so ein bisschen rechts und links oder so. Ach so, die haben schon richtig so about to break, wow, wow, wow, wow und dann so Airwalk auch in der Luft und so, also das ist eigentlich alles richtig geil. Ampsey Hammer, der erfunden immer karener haben die damit mitgemacht bären sind eigentlich super cool bären sind aber auch überrepräsentiert genau wie behörnte tiere in sternzeichen es gibt zu viele behörnte tiere in sternzeichen und da sind wir wieder stefans kritik an den Sternzeichen. Stefans Astrologiestunde. Hi. Schönen guten Abend, ich freue mich sehr, Ihnen die Sterne zu lesen. Wir haben unseren ersten Anrufer. Hallo, wen darf ich begrüssen? Ja, hallo, ich bin der Florentin. Hallo Florentin. Und ich wollte einfach mal wissen, was die Sterne für mich so in petto haben. Alles klar, was soll ich tun? Soll ich dir deine Hand lesen, soll ich dir, dann musst du deine FaceTime-Kamera anmachen und deine Hand zeigen. Soll ich dir Tarot-Karten legen oder soll ich einfach das Pendel befragen?
Nee, ich will ja wissen, was die Sterne für mich in petto haben.
In petto haben, alles klar. Verrätst du mir kurz dein Sternzeichen?
Wassermann. Wassermann, hm, wie ich finde das langweiligste Sternzeichen. Ich mag es nicht besonders. Alle anderen fusten ja irgendwie in der Realität, selbst Waage oder Jungfrau. Wassermann hingegen keine wirkliche Beziehung zu Relatable, Everyday Themen. Okay, also erst...
Ich bin der nächste Anrufer in der Leitung.
Wen darf ich jetzt begrüßen?
Ja, hallo, ich bin die Karolin.
Hallo Karolin.
Was darf ich heute für dich tun?
Ja, ich wollte mal wissen, was die Sterne für mich so auf Lager haben.
Wir schauen direkt mal nach was ich gerne die aus dem
aus dem ärmel schütteln wir befragen das pendel verhältst du mir kurz den sternzeichen wieder es ist schon mal aufgefallen dass es so viele behörte sternzeichen gibt Oh, wir haben noch einen anderen Anrufer. Ich glaube, das heisst das.
Ja.
Wir haben gerade noch einen anderen in der Leitung, aber stell dich kurz nochmal vor. Ja, hallo, hier ist die Britta. Hallo Britta, was kann ich heute für dich tun? Ähm, ja, ich... Ja, ich wollte mal wissen, was die Sterne für mich parat haben. So, es gibt zu viele Möglichkeiten, das zu umschreiben, im Deutschen. Ich bin Steinbock. Ich kenne nicht meinen Unterschied zwischen Steinbock und Wille. Ja, okay, ist ein guter Punkt eigentlich, ne? Stolz. Die haben leicht anders gekrümmte ... Ah, die sind immer so stolz, aber anders. Aber auch stolz, dickköpfig. Aber die wollen immer mit dem Kopf durch die Wand. Stier gibt's auch noch. So dumm, dass der wieder dickköpfig ist. Ja, okay. Das ergibt zu viel Sinn, finde ich. Das ergibt einfach zu viel Sinn. Stolz. Ist auch nicht so positiv, ehrlich gesagt. Ich finde es mega. Man kommt eigentlich, also ich finde, finde es gut, dass Firmen mittlerweile Feiertage einfach übernehmen, also Kommerzialisierung von Weihnachten durch den Weihnachtsmann, Santa Claus und so, Coca-Cola und so, da kauft man sich langsam einfach in gesellschaftliche Tradition einfach ein. Wann geht es los? Bei Sternzeichen. Wann sagt man einfach, okay, pass auf, Jungfrau ist irgendwie aus der Zeit gefallen, irgendwie ist irgendwie blöd, was soll das irgendwie, keine Ahnung. Pomber, der Pomber, genau, also einfach der Pomber und dann einfach Sam der Tukan statt Wassermann und da können Firmen doch einfach. Und dann verteilt man das überall kostenlos und so oder macht dann hinten das Horoskop, Tukan Sam. Waage ist jetzt raus, Pampers. Genau, ja. Pampers hat Waage gekauft? Ja, ja. Schatz, hast du diese Meldung gelesen? Pampers hat Waage gekauft? Moment mal, wie Waage? Moment mal, ich ... Das Sternzeichen Waage. Schau mal kurz durch mein Teleskop. Was siehst du? Tatsächlich. Haben sie das Sternzeichen ersetzt? Die haben komplett die Sterne neu angeordnet. Lass mich auch mal kurz reinschauen. Ja. Ist alles neu. Es Ist das Logo von Pampers zu sehen. Moment mal, was ist das daneben an? Ich glaube, das alles nicht. Clark! Ganz schreckliche Lache gehabt, das war. Aber ich fand die sehr süss. Oh Gott, aber es ist mir alles entglitten. Brauchst du was? Da ist ja jegliche Persönlichkeit gerade entglitten, ohne rauszukommen. Das ist kurz, endlich warst du mal du selbst. Ich trage immer Feuchtigkeitscreme mit mir rum und in regelmäßigen Abständen explodiert die einfach in meinem Rucksack. Feuchtigkeitscreme? Ist überall, weil geht viel rum. Aber so diese Dose, diese Aufdränglichkeit, wo die Wärme ist? Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, ich habe eine Hausmarke, ich habe eine Hausmarke und die ist manchmal in brenzligen Situationen, weil ich packe meinen Rucksack immer relativ unaufmerksam und dann zieht man ein Kabel raus und dann zieht es die Feuchtigkeitscreme-Flasche um und die ist dann so auf dem Kopf. Feuchtigkeitscreme-Flasche? Feuchtigkeitscreme-Ausdrück-Flasche. Kannst du mir kurz erklären, was es ist, genau? Es ist eine Feuchtigkeitscreme Flasche. Feuchtigkeitscreme, ausdrückt Flasche. Kannst du mir kurz erklären, was es ist genau? Es ist eine Feuchtigkeitscreme. Flasche. Ja, es ist so eine Plastikflasche halt. Plastikflasche? Ja, wie so eine Shampooflasche. Okay, so eine grosse. Ich weiss nicht, was du denkst. Ich denke noch gar nichts, ich kann mir nichts vorstellen. Jetzt habe ich eine grosse Shampoo-Flasche im Kopf. Ja, genau richtig. So, aber die sind ja nicht drückbar. Aber sind die nicht drückbar? Ja, du kannst da auf eine Shampoo-Flasche draufdrücken. Ich stelle dir so ein Duschdass jetzt gerade. Ja, völlig richtig. Mit so einem grossen Plastikding obendrauf. Warum, wo das herkommen, weiss ich nicht. Duschdass? Nee, ist einfach eine normale Klappe. Klappe klappe so und die hängt da drin und manchmal ist die halt auch so ich bin falsch rum jetzt aber vorsichtig bitte ja hallo hallo da vorne ich bin falsch rum und dann drücke ich mich durch die u-bahn und so und dann oh vorsicht alle sachen fliegen herum ich bin gerade aber falsch rum und Und irgendwann passiert es, dass ich anscheinend mal da draufdrücke, die Tic-Tac-Packung ist vorbeigeflogen. Und einfach Batz und die gesamte Feuchtigkeitscreme-Flasche 0,7 Liter Feuchtigkeitscreme komplett in meinem Rucksack sind. Kompletto. Und da muss man sagen, das Produkt auch loben, der ist dann sehr feucht.
Genau, der ist dann wirklich auf Jahre hinweg, das ist wie Oberlings, der als Kind in die Feuchtigkeitscreme gefallen ist, der sein Leben lang einfach geschmeidige Haut hat, ohne nachcremen zu müssen, was wirklich hilfreich ist. Du musst deinen Rucksack nie nachcremen? Ich muss meinen Rucksack nie nachcremen. Aber es ist immer die furchtbarste Situation, wenn du dann im Zug sitzt und dann willst du dann irgendwie dein Ladekabel rausziehen und es ist so richtig eingeschlonzt in dieser weissen Masse und es ist so, offensichtlich kann ich nicht die Kontenanz bewahren und denken, ah, ganz normal und die Person neben mir mit so einem, was macht er jetzt und ich so so, einfach furchtbar, weil du, das, was du eigentlich als Unterstützung bei dir hast, wendet sich gegen dich. Die Feuchtigkeitscreme, die immer für dich da ist, wendet sich gegen dich und vor allem, es riecht der ganze Waggon einfach. Feuchtigkeitscreme hat diesen Geruch, der einfach den gesamten Waggon einbaut. Gibt es bestimmt geruchlos. Bist du nicht der Schlimmste der Welt? Nee. Aber alle kriegen es mit. Es sieht ein bisschen aus wie so ein 90-Jahre-Film,
irgendwie so E.T., wo du in deinem Rucksack so eine ... Der gesamten Vakon ist nicht der schlimmste der Welt, aber alle kriegen es mit.
Es sieht ein bisschen aus wie so ein 90-Jahre-Film, irgendwie so E.T., wo du in deinem Rucksack so eine gallartartige Lebensform beherbergst. Genau, ich habe so ein Ei gefunden oder so und es schlüpft dann aus im Zug. Der bessere Ausgang für den Kinderfilm, es ist nicht geplatzt, sondern es ist geschlüpft. Okay, genau. wir da abgeboten sind. Aber muss ich im Zug dann so, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, ihn gar nicht verstecken, wenn der Regisseur beim Dreh noch diskutiert. Aber wir haben jetzt nicht extra... Wir sind am Klo, wir sind am Klo. Ich bin im Reiseklo, Reiseklo der Deutschen Bahn. Du bist mit dem Rucksack Interior Reiseklo, du bist mit dem Rucksack ins Reiseklo gegangen. Aber dann sag das doch. Ja. Naomi, Naomi. Hey, Stefan, bla bla bla, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, Naomi, ich beschütze dich, du bist geschlüpft, du hast so feuchte, schöne Haut, pass auf, du musst aufpassen, okay? Oh, hey, pass auf. Es springt ins Klo.
Nein, nein, nein, jetzt reisse Klo der deutschen Bahn. Du kommst aus Versehen auf den Runterspielknopf.
Oh nein, oh nein! Oh nein! Er wäscht sich die Hände. Ja, ich wäscht mich kurz die Hände. Hat aber lange gebraucht. Ja, sorry, manchmal, Sie wissen, der Flammkuchen im Bordbistro. Ja, und das war ein Riesenlacher im Kino. Das war ein Riesenlacher im Kino. Die Szene hat am besten funktioniert. Guck mal, direkt nach dem tragischen Tod war der grösste Lacher. Nee, nicht tot. Fliegt es nicht auf die Strecke dann raus? Ach ja, na klar, es fliegt auf die Strecke, nur um dann sich oben auf so einen Stromkabel zu setzen, Eleni zu sterben. Das war die kleine Naomi. Das war ein kleiner Trailer aus dem neuen Film Naomi, der geschrieben wurde, komplett von Leuten, die von im Streik befindlichen Reitern, die keine Zeit hatten. Genau, von Kindern, die wir engagiert haben, anstatt professionellen Autoren zu schreiben und stellt sich raus, geht, geht, geht so, geht schon, passt schon. Okay, das heißt, du fasst ab und zu deinen Rucksack und der ist komplett voll mit Feuchtigkeitscreme. Du musst verstehen, ja, bei Feuchtigkeitscreme, ich weiß nicht, wer zieht und wer drückt, verstehst du? Elaboriere. Weil wenn du Feuchtigkeitscreme auf der Haut hast... Sagt die Haut, saug die...
Mehr, mehr, mehr. Saug die Haut des Rhein oder drückt die Feuchtigkeitscreme rein. Sie zieht ein, sagt man ja. So, aber aus wessen Perspektive? Wann zieht die denn in die neue Wohnung ein? So, aber einziehen. Drückt euch der Vermieter rein. Einziehen ist ja, ich gehe rein, da ist ja die Wohnung passiv. Ich finde nämlich, die Creme sagt, zieht schnell ein. Finde ich, klingt so, als würde die Creme den Anspruch erheben und das wollen. Es wird eine aktive Sache der Creme. Das heißt, die Creme im Rucksack wird nie eingezogen. Ich glaube, die Creme sagt... Die bleibt, wo sie ist. Weil ich weiss immer nicht genau, weil ich denke mir, Feuchtigkeitsgeben... Ach ja gut, die verschwindet ja immer auf der Haut, also wird die auch verschwinden. Aber stimmt das? Wer ist hier am Drücker? Die Haut saugt das ein. Das ist eine wundervolle Symbiose. Die Haut sagt... Was machen wir damit jetzt? Die Creme sagt... Wo ist das jetzt? Jetzt stehst du da. Jetzt ist da alles voll mit der weissen Schmarrn da. Ja, was denn? Hi. Was? Wir sind, ich bin Nivea und das ist mein Mann Panthen und wir wollten fragen, ob wir einziehen können. Ja, wir haben jetzt ja eh ein Platz frei, ein Platz frei.
Ein Platz frei?
Ja, wir haben eh ein Platz frei.
Ich weiß ja nicht, was das bedeuten soll.
Ja, kommt's einig.
Ich verstehe sie leider nicht.
Ich verstehe sie nicht.
Du Lingo.
Kommt's einig.
Jetzt auch Akzente und Dialekte.
Ja, oder ist das jetzt Hautkrebs oder was passiert gerade jetzt?
Also ich dachte, wir sind eine Creme, die einzieht. Creme-Werbung.
Ich dachte, du willst symbolisieren, dass einzieht. Creme-Werbung.
Ich dachte, du willst symbolisieren, dass es aus beidseitiges Verständnis ist.
Wollte ich auch.
Aber dann hatte der diesen Akzent und ich dachte, ah, vielleicht verstehe ich den nicht.
Und dann dachte ich, ah, vielleicht sind wir doch in einer anderen Werbung für was anderes.
Ach so.
Ich dachte, das ist jetzt irgendwie so ein Hautkrebs.
Erkennen Sie die Anzeichen früh, wenn die Creme nicht einzieht. irgendwie sowas. Ja, wenn für die Creme kein Zimmer mehr frei ist. Genau, super. Leicht verständlich, leicht verdaulich. Okay. Herr Reyn. Aber espanol? Na, das machen wir gar nicht erst. Da fangen wir gar nicht erst an. Na, das machen wir nicht. Na, das haben wir schon immer so gemacht. Sei tolerant, die Einwandererbehörde. Deutsche Zentrum für Einwanderung. Innenministerium. Ein Programm des Innenministeriums. Ich habe das Gefühl, Ihre Agentur ist in den Werbungen, weil ich meine... Wir verrennen uns halt. Sie haben doch auch so eine Werbung gedreht für vegetarische Ernährung. Wie sah die denn nochmal aus? Ja, herein. Hallo, ich bin ein Fleischstück. Ja, sauber. Gemeine. Ja, kann ich hier rein? Der frisst mir auf. Nee. Ich bin nämlich blöd, deswegen nehmen sie mich nicht auf. Und es gibt keine anderen Werbeagenturen, es ist einfach keine andere Möglichkeit. Also ich dachte gerade, dass das Fleischstück nimmt sich blöd und wird deswegen nicht aufgenommen. Machen Sie es wie Alois, geben Sie Fleisch keine Chance. Okay, folgende Idee. Bevor wir drehen, schreiben wir... Wir schreiben alle Mitarbeiter dieser Agentur... Ich würde sagen, bevor wir drehen, wie wäre es, wenn wir erst vor dem Dreh einmal aufschreiben, was wir drehen wollen. Und dann drehen wir den Spot und wissen schon, was passiert. Weil so ist es immer, wie einer kommt. Und es war alles nur eine Drehbuchprogramm-Werbung für Final Draft 12. Yes, 12. Stark. Hol's euch jetzt. Aber das können wir doch nur, wir können das ja gar nicht installieren, ich habe gar kein Macbook. Macbooks. Kauft euch jetzt ein Macbook. Aber es war doch eine Macbook-Werbung. Willst du Feuchtigkeitscreme? Ja, gerne. Ja, gerne, ohne Scheisse, ich würde die wirklich gerne haben. Ich verstehe eh nicht, warum du so viel Feuchtigkeitscreme brauchst, weil du hast kein Problem mit trockenen Händen.
Es ist nicht ein Problem, was du besitzt hast. Aber das ist jetzt halt, sorry, das geht nicht, die Feuchtigkeitscreme selber ist voll eingehüllt in Feuchtigkeitscreme.
Ja, hätte ich gerne. Wie ist es heute passiert?
Ja, aber ist doch nicht schlimm.
Aber zeig, aber...
Dann können wir auch den Leuten zeigen, die, ah, okay, es ist wirklich einfach eine Shampoo-Flasche.
Es ist so seltsam, dass das, ich, jetzt verstehe ich auch das Problem. Ich verstehe das Problem. Du kannst es ein Bild zeigen. Du kannst es ein Bild zeigen. Da haben wir was, die Leute bei Patreon freuen sich, dass sie endlich mal was sehen. Aber ohne Scheiß, das sieht für mich schon nach dem Problem aus. Es ist nämlich genau eine Shampoo-Flasche. Ich habe diese Erklärung erst nicht gekauft, weil ich dachte, wer hat denn sowas in seiner... Weil die ist ja viel zu steif. Deswegen explodiert die natürlich auch. Warum denn zu steif? Die ist doch super. Oh Gott, das ist aber jetzt viel. Aber die ist ja viel zu steif. Du brauchst eine viel weichere. Oder, was ich dir schenken werde, ist von Nivea... Oh, das ist die perfekte Menge. Wollte ich die Steinsinscreme von Nivea diese kleinen Döschen, die du aufdrehst.
Nee, die finde ich ganz furchtbar.
Wieso denn?
Die mag ich überhaupt nicht.
Aber dann siehst du, dann bist du vielleicht gerade ein bisschen zu stur, um dieses Problem in den Griff zu bekommen.
Nee, mir geht es ja um die Konsistenz. Ich mag das ja, wenn es so richtig schluss.
Ich verdünne es ja eigentlich nochmal mit Wasser.
Und gerade so dieses festere Zeug mag ich überhaupt nicht.
Okay, gut, wenn du genau weisst, was du willst, dann musst du mit dem Problem wieder einfach leben lernen. Es riecht fantastisch, es riecht gut, nach Lilie. Der kommt dir bekannt vor, der Geruch. Ich hab's gerade nur gelesen. Sag mal, ist das Lilie? Sag mal. Schatz, hast du eine Supernase? Wie bitte? Ich bin immer gut gerochen, ja meinst du? Frauke Demrich aus Bottrop wettet, dass sie aus fünf Milliarden Pflanzen zwei, äh, fünf von sechs am Geruch erkennt. Hier ist Will Smith, der dazuguckt. Hey guys, nice to meet you. Wow, this sounds crazy. Five billion, that's quite a lot. It's almost as many as people have seen my movies. Wow, and they didn't smell nice, I can tell you that. I think she can do it. She has a great nose, big, big, nostrils, big nose, and I think, well, she, yeah, I think she has a flower thing, and yeah, I think she can do it. And if she doesn't, I will take the punishment as a man and will take the pain and take the suffering, the despair and all the shame that will come upon me. I will take it on me and I will endure it. I will endure it. Wird denn das so begehrt geworden? Boah, es ist so feucht, es ist so unangenehm. Aber ich fand das ganz interessant, dich zu beobachten, weil das sagt schon was über den Menschen aus, wie er dieses komische Kneten, diese eigene Hände kneten, was so kein Ziel hat, sondern das ist einfach so eine Aneinanderreihung von Verteilung und es hat auch was Verzauberndes, es hat auch sowas Plottenes.
Ich mag Menschen nicht Ideen machen und das machst du nämlich.
Das machst du. Wirklich? Das fühlt sich komisch an für mich.
Leute machen nämlich manchmal, nehmen quasi alle ihre vier Finger und verteilen so ihre Creme darüber.
Und solche Leute sind mir wahnsinnig unsympathisch, weil die nicht verstehen, dass die nicht übereinander geschoben werden wollen.
Die existieren nebeneinander. Jeder ist gleich viel wert.
Du brauchst ja die Zwischenräume der Finger, die sind ja anfällig.
Deswegen machst du ja den. Und dann dieses komikhafte Drehen der Hände in sich selbst.
Ich weiß schon, ihr hört den Podcast vermutlich und seht es nicht so viel.
Könnt ihr euch mal ein bisschen mehr wieder was für eure hörenden Hörerschaft machen?
Sehe ich auch so.
Ja doch, du hast recht, ich mache es schon ein bisschen so, aber ich dreh es am Ende dann noch so richtig ein. Auch etwas, was man nie beigebracht bekommt. Wie Masturbieren und das im Prinzip. Ja genau, niemand von uns weiß, ob er nicht völlig falsch masturbiert. Beim Masturbieren finde ich es wirklich spannend, weil das ist ja wirklich etwas, was du komplett alleine beginnst. Klar, gibt es Ausnahmen, Freunde, Sleepover beim Buddy und man experimentiert oder whatever oder Keks, Wixen, ich weiß nicht, ob diese ganzen Sachen Urban Myth sind oder so, gibt es alles, aber die ersten Male vermutlich macht man das alleine, weil es ja auch schambeachtet ist und sowas und es ist nicht etwas, was der Vater dir beibringt, hoffentlich, sondernondern es ist vermutlich etwas. Also du sagst, es sollte sich ändern, oder? Äh, nee, nee. Also da verstehe ich mich da jetzt, also bitte nicht falsch. Versteht mich da nicht falsch. Auch ein guter Satz eigentlich, verstehe ich mich nicht falsch. Ja, als ob man immer irgendwann mal das Gegenteil wollte. Meinst du, das männliche Masturbieren oder das weibliche Masturbieren ist intuitiver. Oder wo sagt man eher, das sei ja komplett falsch. Ich war ja meilenweit entfernt. Ich glaube, ich muss den Finger oben rein. Ich habe ja komplett, ich lage ja völlig falsch, völlig daneben einfach, funktioniert ja gar nicht.
Nee, aber ich habe mal herausge... Also Kuppel hat die Theorie, es zwei arten hatte lange die theorie dass zwei arten von von von männlicher masturbation gibt nämlich seine theorie war es gibt bauchwechser und taschentuchwechser okay zwei also es gibt manche die sich in tüchli be der reich, es ist von den zwei Freunden, die du hast, okay, es grenzt sich langsam ein. Ob man sich ein Taschentuch beiseite legt oder ein Küchentuch oder whatever, oder kann auch ein T-Shirt oder Socke sein, oder halt ob man auf den Bauch direkt und dann wäscht man sich ab. Es gibt zwei verschiedene und ich habe das auch irgendwann gecheckt, dass ich da, da
haben wir uns zum ersten Mal davon erzählt und so was und man merkt, ah okay, ich mache
es ganz anders als alle anderen.
Ja, ich bin der Gurkenwichser, so eine komplett andere Kategorie, die es so gar nicht gibt.
Und dann haben wir es mal ausgebreitet, diese Theorie im Freundeskreis und einer gesagt,
nee, ich mache keines davon und wir alle so, hä, was machst du denn? Ja, direkt ins Klo. Ja, okay. Und das fand ich super interessant. Ja. Weil, wie kann das denn passieren? Ja. Ja. Wie kann das denn, aber was ist denn da schiefgelaufen? Hat er noch nie einen Film gesehen? Weil die anderen, er war dann auch überzeugt, dass die anderen Ideen besser sind. Aber es ist ja kein brainstorming. So ein konstruktives Gespräch mit 24, wo man sagt, okay, da kann ich echt noch einmal arbeiten. Da habe ich mich wirklich verrannt. Da habe ich mich wirklich mal verrannt jetzt. Fand ich super interessant. Und ich habe auch gesagt, krass, er hat mit bislang noch niemandem darüber gesprochen. Sonst hätte er ja sehr früh, wäre er ja das Korrektiv Gesellschaft aufgetreten, hätte gesagt, ah, du machst das falsch oder nicht optimal. Also du sagst, es soll in der Schule direkt beigebracht werden oder mehr. Genau, also ein Lehrer muss aber in den Schatten springen. Es gibt dann einen Lehrer pro Schule, der sagt, der Hohen war in Herrn Ulrichsen. Ich habe morgen, Mama, ich habe morgen zweite, ich muss erst zur zweiten Stunde, aber ich habe Masturbation bei Herrn Ulrichsen. Mama, es fühlt sich so an, als willst du gar nicht in diesem Sketch sein. Naja, ich habe gerade ganz andere Probleme. Geht zur Schule. Mama, was hast du zu tun? Geh zur Schule. Ich will lieber die Probleme. Ich will nicht zu Schule. Geh zur Schule, meine Junge. Nein, ich möchte mich lieber um deine Probleme kümmern. Geh zur Schule. Mama, ernsthaft, ich will mich inhaltlich lieber mit deinen Problemen auseinandersetzen, als jetzt in diesem Sketch weiter in die andere Richtung zu gehen, okay? Mama, ich wäre lieber bei dir und deinen Problemen. Ernsthaft, ich glaube, es ist besser für den ganzen Podcast, wenn ich mich um deine Probleme kümmere, Mama. Nee, ist okay. Das ist okay. Die Küchenrolle ist schon wieder leer. Ja, ne, die gehen schnell leer. Die ist schon wieder leer. Oh, ich bin so erleichtert, dass du das Thema ansprichst. Die gehen immer so schnell leer. Die ist so schnell leer. Und dann fragt man sich, wo ist die Zeit geblieben, wo sind die ganzen Papiere geblieben.
Apropos, auf Reddit haben wir immer eine sehr aktive Community, das wollte ich schon ansprechen, und zwar wurde letztens gepostet die feuchten fünf, oder nee, warte, die äh. Die feuchten fünf? Die kühlen fünf, und zwar Kinder präsentiert die kühlen fünf. Gott, Gott hat sein Veto. Du sollst keine Götter neben mir haben, wie oft soll ich das denn noch sagen? Aber die kühlen fünf sind schon cool. Kinder Maxi King, Kinder Pinguie, Kinder Schokofresh, Kinder Milchschnitte und der gesuchte Fünfte im Bunde. Kinder Paradiso. Was ist das denn nochmal? Ja, das ist ist die grosse Frage. Kinderparadiso wird diese fünf werden als die kühlen fünf offiziell angekündigt mit witzigen Sketchen auf YouTube haha, die sind zu fünft unterwegs und erleben Abenteuer. Es gibt natürlich den coolen, den sexy Typen, den witzigen, den Draufgänger so, ich glaube wir alle wissen, wer wer ist. Den für diese Aktion viel zu sexy Typen. Der einfach richtig lasziv ist. Und als ich das gelesen habe, dachte ich, okay, geil, Paradiso ist jetzt offiziell im Angebot und stellt sich raus, nein, nur in bestimmten Supermärkten gibt es Paradiso. Paradiso ist was ganz Merkwürdiges, ist so, glaube ich, so eine Vanille-Zitrone-Schnitte, ist so was Zitroniges mit so einem fluffigen bisküttel mit so einer creme für mich bis jetzt immer die inkarnation von italien ich habe das immer in italien gegessen und jetzt habe ich angst davor dass es hierher kommt und ich mir diese kindheitserinnerung kaputt mache weil ich werde mir das natürlich in die kelle schieben so wenn ich das hier in offener wildbahn sehe weil es eigentlich eine feine Sache ist, weil weil du hast da, also es ist keine Handschnitte, es sieht eher in Richtung Kuchen.
Es sieht aus wie eine weisse Milchschnitte. So, und völlig richtig, du denkst jetzt eine Milchschnitte, denkst du, ah, nehme ich in die Hand und esse ich. Ja. Nein, nein, nein.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no. Denn Paradiso wird in einem praktischen Papierschuber geliefert.
Papier im Papier?
Ne, ich meine wirklich Karton. Ah. Ich meine wirklich Karton. Also Kartonpapier, wie ähnlich des Exquisa Käsekuchen Snack, Stange. Das hat ja auch nochmal so eine Schale unten drin. Keiner schmeckt mir so. Oh, wie dieser. Wo du es nochmal rausschieben kannst. Und ähnliches Paradies auch, nur vielleicht noch, finde ich noch ein bisschen cleverer, weil da hat dieses Papierteil in der Mitte noch einen Knickpunkt, so dass du es an einer Seite annimmst, die Vorderseite nach hinten knickst und dann einen Haltegriff hast und vorne der Paradies so rausschaut. Okay. Weil du kannst natürlich nicht greifen, weil oben Puderzucker drauf ist. All das wird für euch
in Zukunft völlig
normal sein, wenn Kinder Paradiso
jetzt tatsächlich offiziell
von Kindern als Teil der kühlen
fünf aufgeführt wird.
Rein vom
Klang fände ich,
die kühlen vier
wäre genauso gegangen. Nein, die kühlen
fünf, auch dass es ü doppelt drin ist, superschön. Die kühlen fünf wäre genauso gegangen. Nein, die kühlen fünf, auch dass es ü doppelt
drin ist, super schön. Fünf? Die kühlen
fünf finde ich viel besser. Du meinst,
die haben nur Paradiso hinzugefügt, damit
es besser klingt, die kühlen fünf. Genau.
Das heißt, es ist so eine Karte Quote entscheidend.
Und fünf ist ja die viel bessere Zahl.
Na. Top zehn,
wir machen die top neun Zahlen. Die top
neun Zahlen einstelligen,
nee, die top zehn einstelligen Zahlen, also von null bis neun. Top ten Ziffern. Wir machen nur die top drei, weil bei mir ist auf Platz drei die sieben. Die drei kriegt die fünf bei mir. Die fünf ist dann auf der drei. Ja. Warum? Fünf ist eine gute Zahl. Fünf. Dies ist eine gute Zahl. Eine Hand. Die ist viel höher bei mir die fünf ist noch der drei warum fünf ist eine gute zahl fünf diese gute zahl
der hand ist viel höher bei mir fünf fünf malzeiten am tag fünf ist ein gutes ding du hast so ein pentagon ja okay fünf eck wunderbar natürlich aber bei mir ist die die sieben auf der fünf Die sieben Gebote, ne, die sieben Tod sind, die sieben Tod sind, es ist eben eine Glückszahl auf dem Markt, sieben hat was, hat der Eidchen was. Das heilige Schwert wurde in sieben Teile zerteilt, die sieben Phantome und sowas. Ja, dann bei mir auf Platz zwei die drei. Ne, Platz zwei ist bei mir die sieben. Die Comedy drei. Platz zwei ist bei mir die sieben. Die Comedy drei, so, die Witze funktionieren nach einer drei, die drei ist ja wichtig, in Aufzählungen ist die drei, dann macht ihr einen guten Punkt, wenn ihr eine drei seid, also von daher. Frühstück, Frühstück, Mittagessen, Abendessen. Genau. Drei ist einfach die Zahl, deswegen ist die bei mir auch auf eins. Herbst, Sommer, Winter. So, also, ne, das ziehe ich durch, die die Comedy-Stift auf Platz eins, bei mir auf Platz eins nämlich die fünf. Interessant, dass wir die gleichen drei Zahlen haben, aber in einer Reihenfolge. Beweist die Fün auch auf eins. Herbst, Sommer, Winter. So, also, das ziehe ich durch. Bei mir ist es die fünf.
Interessant, dass wir die gleichen drei Zahlen
haben, aber in einer Reihenfolge.
Bei mir ist es fünf auf Platz eins, weil,
bestes Beispiel, du feierst kein
siebenjähriges und kein dreijähriges,
aber du feierst ein fünfjähriges. Exakt.
Schach, Matt,
Rhetorikkurs habe ich belegt.
Fünfjähriges feiert man.
Du feierst ein 25-jähriges zum Beispiel, weil es die Mitte ist, genau die Mitte. Und dann alle anderen guten Punkte, die du gesagt hast, Menschen haben fünf Finger und fünf zehn. An fünf zehn können wir uns alles abziehen. Sag mal, dieser Rhetorikkurs, der zahlt sich immer noch Woche um Woche aus. Du hast einfach fünf zehn. Ich meine nur, fünf ist sehr wichtig, aber was mir gerade aufgefallen ist, was du nicht aufgezählt hast in den Top drei, ist die vier. Das stimmt, aber Stefan. Also gerade meinst du, die vier ist genauso wichtig, genauso gut wie die fünf. Die vier fruchtigen, nein, wie heißt das nochmal? Die fünf feuchten. Die vier kühlen. Ein kleines Gegenargument. Als wir gerade dieses witzige Segment des Podcasts gemacht haben. Ja. Haben wir da eine Top 5?
Hat er die Gorilla gesehen, der mir da rund durchgelaufen ist.
Nee, haben wir da eine Top 5 gemacht oder eine Top 3?
Ich hab's, um abzukürzen.
Guck mal, auf Platz 1 der Top 3
muss doch die 3 sein.
Du kannst doch nicht eine Top 3 machen.
Wann hast du den Grittorikurs gemacht?
Und dann sagen, ist es auf Platz 1 eine 5. Nee Nee, Stefan, Schachmatt Uno Reverse. Die Kategorie, die Podcast-Kategorie heisst literally die Grossen Fünf. Nein, die Top Drei. Die Grossen Fünf. Na, dann machen wir den Jingle. Die Grossen Fünf, präsentiert von Tietze und Will. zum kühlen Kinderartikel geht, würde ich ja sogar noch das Kinderbuehne mit reinpacken, denn es schmeckt viel besser gekühlt. Leute,
ich finde sogar die Milch sind da rein. Schmeißt das
Maxi-King raus und macht eine Milch,
macht die Kinderriegel rein und
die Buenos für das Drecksparadies so.
Dann habt ihr fünf Kühle, die sind zwar
nicht alle im Kühlregal, aber
sind alle geil kühl. Ich sehe, da kommt ein Krieg
auf uns zu. Die kühlen fünf,
ich glaube, das ist so wie so eine... Gegen die fünf
Fruchtigen. Ja, das ist wie so eine Mafia-Familie,
wo es immer fünf gibt, aber
die werden alle gegenseitig ermordet und dann kommt
Vielen Dank. auf uns zu. Die kühlen fünf, ich glaube, das ist so wie so eine... Gegen die fünf fruchtigen. Ja, das ist wie so eine Mafia-Familie,
wo es immer fünf gibt, aber die werden alle gegenseitig ermordet und dann kommt
irgendwie der Kinderriegel rein. Ich will
mehr Stories aus
Produktsicht. Aber ich will ja die
feuchten fünf.
Ich will ja die feuchten fünf
haben. Ja, was meinst du damit? Fünf
Feuchtigkeitscremes
mit verschiedenen Charakteren, lustigem, spaßigem Design. Okay, und alle sehen einfach aus wie so ein weisser Blob, wie so ein weisser Flüssigkeits-Blob. Ja, aber es gibt den lustigen Cowboy-Blob mit dem Cowboy-Hut auf und den Stiefeln mit den Sporen und der Pistole, einer geladenen Pistole, dann gibt es den Ninja, den Ninja Blob.
Okay, du willst irgendwie nicht FSK 12 kriegen oder was?
Weil du sagst, sie ist geladen.
Den Ninja Blob mit dem blutigen Nunchuck.
Sind die Kugeln, die der Cowboy Blob schiesst, auch kleine Feuchtigkeit, weil der so, ah, der ist zu trocken, blei.
Er ist blei, tatsächlich.
Ja, es ist voll blei, ja. Und es gibt auch noch blut an den nunchucks von dem blut ja es sind richtige kriege aber aber also dann rotes menschen blut ja aber gegen wen kämpfen dann die fünf feuchten gegen wen kämpfen die wenn wer auch immer sich in denen den weg stellt ja auch immer es sich wagt sich ihnen Weg zu stellen. Ja, und die benutzten Waffen zeigen, ah, Leute haben wohl was gegen Feuchtigkeit einzuwenden. Ich dachte, ihr Feind könnt irgendwie Sand sein oder so oder was Trockenes oder so. Ja, finde ich auch gut. Aber weil du sagst, es ist direkt Blut und. Ja, das ist vielleicht lame, wenn der Sand dran wäre oder Sand in den Schuhen hätten oder sowas. Okay. Sollen ja schon irgendwie coole Charaktere sein.
Okay, wir haben Cowboy, wir haben Ninja. Wie wär's mit so einem klassischen Freischerler? Also so einem klassischen Landsmann. Also mit so einem grossen Hut, mit einer Feder. Ich kann dem an manchen Orten nicht folgen.
Na, ich möchte den... Ich laufe hinter dir her und ich will dir helfen und ich trage auch noch einen Rucksack von dir und so. Und ich laufe mit, aber du sagst dann Dinge und dann kann ich dir nicht mehr folgen. Naja, weil ich finde, es gibt so ein paar archetypische Kostüme zum Beispiel. Pirat, Ritter, so, Zauberer, Mexikaner, Cowboy. Ich will in diese Liste den Freischärle, den 30-jährigen Krieg Freischäler mit einer Akebuse, mit einem grossen Hut, mit einer Feder, mit diesen Pluderhosen, mit verwirrender Heraldik, den will ich da mal so ein bisschen reinbringen, irgendwie so. Also, du willst Heraldik den Freischärler reinbringen? Ja, warum denn nicht? Mit einer Hakebuse. Mit einer Hakebuse.
Freischärler, meinst du? Ja. Wenn man es googelt, findet man nicht coole Sachen. Ja, einfach der gut dreissigjähriger Krieg halt einfach mal so ein Musketier. So was in der Ecke. Aber ich will es noch ein bisschen mehr mit so einer knallgelb-rot gestreiften Hose. Okay, wir haben wie die Schweizer Garde. So was genau, genau so was in der Richtung. Okay, dann haben wir den Schweizer Gardisten, das Geschmack Richtung Zitrone, nee, Geruchsrichtung Zitrone. Genau, ja. Das ist meinetwegen der dritte im Bunde. Dann gibt es noch so einen Henker mit so einer spitzen und augenverdeckenden, anonymisierenden Maske. Und was ich noch witzig fände, so ein Häftling, der so eine Eisenkugel an dem Fuss hat, der immer so guckt und der so einen gestreiften Anzug anhat. Und das wäre dann Geruchsrichtung Mond.
Klare Mondnacht.
Ja, der perfekte Moment zum Ausbrechen.
Genau, super, super, super. Okay, das sind die feuchten fünf. Was wäre ein klassischer Plot? Also, ich stelle es mir so vor, feucht Hauptquartier, alle sitzen um den Tisch rum, gelangweilt, nichts passiert. Reiben sich die Hände mit Feuchtigkeitscreme ein. Plötzlich das grosse rote Telefon leuchtet und klingelt. Genau, Ninja beschbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbbb Sie sprechen mit den fünf Feuchten? Schnell, hier trocknet alles aus. Es hat seit Tagen nicht geregnet. Hier ist alles trocken. Ich kann kaum noch sprechen. Es ist alles so trocken. Hier reisst der Boden auf. Wir sind nur für Hautrisse und so zuständig. Ciao. Und dann warten Sie auf den Anruf der Passen. Ma, ich habe gerade drüber nachgedacht, was du gesagt hast, dass das Telefon ja gar nicht Geräusch machen muss, wenn es blinkt. Da habe ich aber überlegt, was ist, wenn alle nicht hingucken, während es blinkt. Sehr unwahrscheinlich, wir sind verfünft. Das muss man ausrechnen, wie wahrscheinlich ist es, dass wir alle in andere Richtungen gucken. In dem Moment. Okay, also wenn jeder von uns in eine zufällige Richtung guckt. Genau. Und wir sind gleichmässig im Raum verteilt. Wie viele Richtungen gibt es? 360, sagen wir mal 360 Grad. Ja, aber ich sehe es ja auch, wenn ich bei 361 gucke. Und es steht auf 360, sehe ich es ja auch noch. Weißt du? Wie gross ist dein Winkel, in dem du das Telefon noch wahrnimmst? Das müssen wir herausfinden. Okay, also Wahrnehmungs...ichtfeld sichtfeld augewinkel das müssen wir erst mal heraus okay 45 es bringt schon wieder mal kurz aus weil wir können gerade ich stehe den checker ich stehe also den stecker gerade mal 60 grad bis maximal 60 grad ja okay vier richtungen genau 60 grad vier Himmelsrichtungen? Nee, sechs. Das ist ein Sechstel. Gibt es deswegen sechs Himmelsrichtungen? Also, jeder hat eine Sechstel Chance, das Telefon zu sehen. Und wir sind fünf. Es ist also sehr, ich finde, da sollten wir dann schon das Geräusch ausmachen, weil es nervtötend ist.
Okay.
Und die Chance, dass wir es nicht sehen, ist sehr gering.
Also wir haben dann ein Sechstel mal ein Sechstel, nee, wir haben fünf Sechstel mal fünf Sechstel, dass es niemand sieht.
Nee, wir können ja auch alle, wir teilen uns die ja nie auf, weißt du?
Die Chance ist nämlich nicht so gross.
Wir teilen uns die ja nie auf.
Wir teilen uns die nie auf. Die Winkel. Es ist nicht so, dass wenn einer in die andere Richtung guckt, die dann besetzt ist, sondern wir könnten auch theoretisch alle nach Osten gucken. Ja, ich würde sagen, jeder guckt in eine zufällige Richtung dafür. Okay, also ein Sechstel, ein Sechstel, ein Sechstel. Ja, dass jemand hinschaut, ja. Sind ein Naja wohl. 542. Nee, ich würde rechnen, fünf Sechstel mal fünf Sechstel mal fünf Sechstel. Das ist die Chance, dass es niemand sieht. Aber es müssen ja nicht fünf Sechstel sein, meine ich ja. Es können ja auch vier Sechstel sein. Doch, jeder hat eine fünf Sechstel Chance, es nicht zu sehen. Und das macht man fünfmal, weil wir sind die fünf Feuchten, was ich langsam das Gefühl habe, dass wir vergessen. Nee, nee. Weil ich meine, okay, aber wäre es nicht schlau, der Freisteller.
Eine Frage noch einmal.
In Anbetracht der aktuellen Faktenlage,
dass ein Sechstel nur ausreicht, um etwas zu sehen,
und wir sind zu fünft, wäre es da nicht schlau, wenn wir ein sechstes Mitglied begrüssen könnten,
so dass wir stets ein Augenmerk auf den Alarmapparello gerichtet haben. Die sechs Feuchten. So. Die sechs Feuchten. Jetzt möchte ich mal kurz das alle, erstmal haben wir die Alliteration gerade verloren. Ich wäre eher für die vier Feuchten als für die sechs Feuchten. Wir müssen auch aufpassen, wenn wir das aussprechen, weil wir sind nicht die sechs Feuchten. Die sechs Feuchten. Okay, noch ein Problem. Das ist schon mal klar. Mach das Propos dann. Und dann möchte ich noch sagen, kann jeder kurz seine Top-3-Zahlen aufschreiben, weil ich glaube, die 6 ist bei niemandem in den Top-3. Was ist denn die nächste Zahl mit F? 15. Die 15 feuchten. Nee, 14. Die 14 feuchten. Eine Menge. Neun Leute, neun Leute. Wir verdienen nichts. Wir verdienen eh schon ich habe wenn wir durch vierzehn teilen müssen ich habe heute aber pass mal auf ich habe heute im bus einen gesehenen ritter und da habe ich mir schon gedacht ich habe einen pirat gesehen und ich habe mir schon gedacht der würde richtig gut zu uns passen es gibt doch vierzehn verschiedene darum geht es mir nicht alles was wir verdienen durch vierze darum, dass wir alles, was wir verdienen, durch vierzehn teilen müssen.
Tekken hat zwanzig Kämpfer oder so.
Umsatzsteuer. Super Smash Brothers.
Wir werden noch vierzehn Leute finden,
die vierzehn feuchten. Und die Chance
bei vierzehn mit einem Sechstel.
Als Freisteller möchte ich nur sagen, ist es mir ein bisschen zu nah am Ritter.
Nee, das stimmt doch
geil, du hast ja keinen Helm auf.
Ja, aber ich bin noch ein Ritterschaff.
Du hast ein Küras, okay. Ein was? Das ist ja keine ganze Rüstung, das ist ja nur ein Küras. Das ist allen klar, das ist uns allen klar. Ich habe einen Küras. Also wenn du sagst, wir nehmen noch einen Kürasier hier mit rein, das ist dann Quatsch. Ich habe ein Musketier gesehen. Ja, aber das ist, sorry, aber das ist genau das Gleiche. Ja, das ist Quatsch. Das ist mir zu ähnlich. Nee, das ist Quatsch. Vor allem, wir können nicht die fünf feuchten und dann noch die drei Musketiere. Ja, aber guck mal, jetzt nebenan sind ja die Turtles, ne? Die sind fast gleich. Wie viele sind das? Das sind vier, die sind fast gleich. Die unterscheiden sich nur in der Bewaffnung und der Farbe. Man kann mehr von einer Sorte haben. Das stimmt, die sind fast gleich. Wir können vier Freischärler haben, solange ihr unterschiedliche Farben habt. Ihr habt doch unterschiedliche Heraldik, wa? Das stimmt, wir haben unterschiedliche Heraldik und Kürasten. Also können wir nicht einfach sagen, wir haben vier Freischärler und dann holen wir uns noch einen Ritter und einen Gespenst oder so und dann haben wir doch schon vierzehn, okay? Ja. Okay? Gut, dann stecke ich das Telefon wieder. Ich wollte erstmal nochmal sagen, danke, dass ihr alle so aufmerksam zugehört habt und so und irgendwie, ich fände es nämlich schön, wenn wir gemeinsam nochmal uns umarmen. Okay, wir kommen nochmal alle zusammen. Wir müssen ein bisschen aufpassen, wenn wir uns zu sehr zusammendrücken, aber ich glaube, für den Moment ist es in Ordnung. Dass wir das Telefon übersehen? Nee, dass wir uns zu fest zusammendrücken. Ach so. Wir sind feucht. Was soll da passieren? Naja, komm, einmal eine Gruppenumarmung. Hey. Oh nein! Wir sind im Rucksack! Wir sind im Rucksack! Nein! Tick-Tack wieder vorbeigeflogen. Und wir wundern uns, warum wir keine Produkte verkauft haben mit dieser spannenden Marketingaktion. Ja, das war... Nachdem die erste Werbeagentur zugemacht war, warum gibt es immer nur eine Werbeagentur zu jeder Zeit? Was ist das für ein... Adenauer hat das Gesetz erlassen, dass es... Die Regel der zwei. Es gibt die Master-Werbeagentur und es gibt immer die Schüler-Master-Agentur. Und das hat Adenauer so ins Gesetz gegossen, das kriegen wir nicht mehr raus. Genau, George Lucas und Adenauer haben es gemeinsam ins Gesetz gegründet. In einer noch nie dagewesenen waghalsigen Kooperation haben Konrad Adenauer und George Lucas das deutsche Grundgesetz für immer geprägt. Die Regel der zwei, es gibt aber eine Werbeagentur. Herr Lukas, was haben Sie sich dabei gedacht? Nun, also am Anfang dachte ich, dass vielleicht einer genug wäre. Aber dann, auf eine gewisse Art, kommt man dann ans Ende der Geschichte und man erreicht nicht das komplette Potential der Geschichte, sondern man will es wirklich, weil es eine gewisse Dynamik, die sich entwickelt, es gibt coole Emotionen, die auf dem Spiel stehen und naja, ich dachte einfach zwei wäre die perfekte Nummer und es ist nicht die beste Nummer, drei ist eine ziemlich gute Nummer, aber fünf ist für mich die perfekte Nummer. Und immer wenn jemand etwas anderes behauptet, dann muss man das anzweifeln, weil fünf ist wirklich die beste Nummer. Ich meine, man feiert ja den fünften Geburtstag, man feiert den dritten nicht. Aber Herr Lucas, Sie haben ja immer Filme in Dreierkonstellationen gedreht. Ui. Und damit möchte ich mich verabschieden von euch aus dieser Folge. Für die drei. Ihr wisst, was ihr zu tun habt da draußen. Ich möchte mich nicht verabschieden. Ich bleibe hier noch ein bisschen sitzen. Aber geh du ruhig schon mal. Dann gehe ich schon mal. Und dann macht's gut. Tschüss, dann fahre ich heute alleine los. Ich mag es hier draußen zu sitzen, vor dem Ufo, mit diesem Klappstuhl. Ich mach mir noch ein Bierchen auf. Okay, ich würde schon, ist es okay, wenn ich schon abhebe, oder soll ich warten? Nee, wenn du kurz einfach dann warten könntest, dann warte ich kurz. Ich fahr da einfach kurz aus und dann. Gut, dann verabschieden wir schon mal. Tschüss und dann bis nächste Woche. Wir heben dann später ab, was ungefähr so klingt. Fuck, jetzt muss ich ...
Flotin ist gruselig draußen. Es ist ein bisschen gruselig, wenn man so alleine draußen ist. Allein. Du sitzt ja immer noch hier, Mensch. Ja. Du sitzt ja immer noch da. Ist so alles okay, du bist so nachdenklich.
Ja, ich habe immer über diese ganze Diskussion nachgedacht mit der drei oder der fünf und ich dachte, vielleicht haben wir beide recht. Und die acht ist das Beste.
Oder die vier.
Acht durch zwei, ja ja oder zwei mal zwei ja
lasse abheben okay kommen wir heben ab mensch schlagen wir noch vorzuhören alles klar tschüss Tschüss, ne, macht's gut, wir heben ab!
It's the worst bird production. Es ist eine Worst Bird-Produktion. Jede Ecke anders, jede Story echt. Späti-Romantik an der Trinkhalle, Beats unterm Förderturm, Sonnenuntergang auf der Halde.
Klingt anders? Ist es auch. Dein Ruhrgebiet, wo das Unperfekte perfekt passt.
Inspiration für deinen Next-Level-Städtetrip gibt's auf Insta, mein.ruhrgebiet.